Jo I'm very happy to have you today I am
going to ask you for questions regarding
the Euro uh EU directive on combating
sexual violence but also domestic
violence I'm a content creator I make
videos on YouTube which means that I'm
more interested in the online aspect of
it I would say but of course like I'm
going to ask you a bunch of uh questions
relating to it the idea is to kind of uh
have a more general idea of what the
directive stands for and how is it going
to apply to people's lives really so I
guess my first question would be um you
know looking back on like the recent
history we're kind of evolving after the
the Metro movement for example so that
happened like more than five years ago
now and if we really go to the roots of
movement it even started like way before
that um so I wanted to ask you like how
has the parliament responded to to the
the movement what has been done since
then and what how does the the directive
fit into that well I think what the
parliament is doing is looking at the
world around us and saying my God there
is so much violence against women in all
sorts of forms whether it's rape
domestic violence female genital
mutilation sexual assaults the whole me
too movement what that kind of
personified and the Parliament for the
first time believe it or not is saying
we have a directive to try and get the
same standard right across Europe in
relation to how countries deal with
violence against women and domestic
violence even right people deal with it
in all sorts of different ways some
countries have consent issues uh
involved in the definition others don't
so what we're doing is try and bring
standards across Europe into how all of
these issues are dealt with and get so
that if you're in Croatia or you're in
Ireland or you're in France and you're a
woman traveling around you can know that
the law is going to you know both
protect you prosecute those who might
attack you and you know and and prevent
in the first place these kind of crimes
so it's interesting because since then
the notion of consent has become quite
important especially in online discs we
very much focus on this notion of
consent but like how how do countries
kind of you know react to this notion
and is it like a broad consensus or do
you have some oh I wouldn't say so I
mean I for some strange reason to most
of us as women why is consent so
difficult to put into your law like is
it some primitive fear that you know
women all over the place are going to
start accusing men of O of rape if you
bring in the consent issues but you know
we've dealt with tricky things in our
laws before uh you can look at issues of
consent and you can Define them and say
was the woman capable o of giving
consent what were the
circumstances practical psychological
from a mental health point of view from
everything was the consent given Yes
means yes uh was that given and if it
wasn't given then what we're saying is
that that is a crime that needs to be
prosecuted and it needs to be part of
the way that we deal with rape across
the member states how do you do you take
into account the sort of stage in terms
of like the political discourse uh in
different countries like do you try to
adapt the directive to uh you know
different stages in each country or do
you try to provide something we what we
try in the parliament is to have
standards we have a really good report
on on the directive on violence against
women it's got everything in it with the
we want to see high standards about
prevention prosecution protecting women
but of course when you're dealing with a
council you know all the different Prime
Ministers then they're coming from very
different places and we're having to
negotiate with them it's not that you
take account but will they agree to the
high standards that we're suggesting
will they go with it or will they resist
it and that's what we're going to find
out over the next few weeks uh and
countries have very different attitudes
to conscent many countries you know
don't have if you like state-of-the-art
legislation about consent even of rape
so like that that's the problem like how
do you get to the point where you get
this a directive right from the European
uh institutions that's about setting
standards in the members all the member
states have to they have to bring in a
directive so they're very careful about
what they agree to at a European level
because they they may not want to bring
it in more conservative governments may
say no no we don't want consent in our
legislation and you mentioned also like
the sort of um political aspect right
it's not just about the directive it's
not just about wom's rights or about
like the the power of the EU so can you
expand on that a little bit yeah it's a
little bit you know there's different
excuses made or even arguments made so
some of the member states will say they
may not want this for all the reasons
you and I've just discussed but equally
it may be uh also a legal argument that
says we do not want Europe telling us
what way our criminal uh law ought to
work but on the other hand with murder
we have a common definition all across
Europe haven't we why not on rape it's
so Insidious there's so many women dying
and being injured how do you feel you
can sort of bring back this motivation
maybe the momentum that we had right
after me to do you think it is where
where where does it happen like at which
level it's a big battle you know I mean
we live in an unfinished
democracy uh unfinished from the point
of view of women and other groups um
there's a lot of everyday sexism if you
look at the pornographic uh industry if
you look at prostitution I mean these
are all areas where people feel they can
buy women um you know and this is built
into the law in some countries so we've
got a lot of work to do we need momentum
we need young and old working together
we need uh Nos and government working
together but it's quite a mountain to
climb actually because it brings in all
of these cultural attitudes you and I
have been talking about and then of
course you get the legal argument as
well so um but look I mean we're
motivated we have it the good news is
that the commission and the Parliament
are united uh we both want to see this
happen it is more complex when you get
to the member states so um we've got a
lot of work to do still but you know
it's it's all about keeping the momentum
there was great momentum with me too but
then like it's a lot of like a lot of
issues they kind of go up and they go
down they go backwards they go forwards
but we have to keep working yeah do you
think social media can play a role in in
absolutely what sort of role could they
play well obviously the more support you
get from the citizen population and we
know that can be heavily influenced by
social media and the more pressure that
uh individuals and groups put on their
governments to say we're not happy with
the definitions we have it's a bit
technical I suppose for people
to but I mean if you say to people look
at your country doesn't have consent
written into its laws about rape well
then I guess that's easily understood uh
and it it's to say we want strong laws
to protect women in our country and
these are high standards coming from
Europe why aren't we agreeing with them
whether we're in X or Y country now it's
interesting because um obviously you
have this no of consent has circulated
online quite well I guess like the
consensus is that yeah there something
you need to take into account now
there's another question that started to
emerge in online Circle as well is this
notion of and I know it it must be
difficult to balance that as well like
as an me meaning that you have to you
know get those laws and you have to to
be as pragmatic as possible U but
basically it's the debate around um
going Beyond punishment you know and how
would you do you implement that in the
directive as well or how would you how
do you feel about that you know like
this idea of um punishment okay sure we
need to get those abusers Etc out of uh
you know prevent that from happening
again but at the same time like is
punishment really the solution to to
what's happening so it's my view is that
you have to have a combination of
approaches you know we need more male
Champions yeah like women talk to women
about this all the time we need male
leaders taking this on as a really
really serious issue that they're going
to lead on so that's another way of
working on this um male champions in
personal lives in local for local you
know communities we need male leaders
who will not tolerate what they see
happening and will speak out um I think
cultural shifts I think information
campaigns are really important um you
know because the attitudes can be built
in in very young boys uh and and young
men uh and if you think you can buy a
woman through prostitution well you know
it's not too far away to think you can
buy consent you know uh in in one way or
another so you know it it's you're right
it isn't punishment is one aspect and
that's important uh but say on on Cyber
violence and cyber crime I think in
Ireland we're using some really good uh
advertising to you know a young man sit
they said but I just threatened to share
an image I wasn't going to do it I
threatened it sorry to threaten is a
crime Now in Ireland and that's a shock
like to a lot of young men and it's a
very good ad that they're used so I
think you've got information education
in universities now we're having consent
uh discussions universities people you
know generally over 8 so that's good I
mean I've seen it as well like uh I mean
I'm 25 now but when I talk with
teenagers teenage boys even like the the
discourse they have on things like
consent is very different from my
generation and you previous it's ongoing
discussion and social media is a great
place to do that yeah Tot but but the
issue with social media and that's also
part of the work I do is the sort of uh
conservative backlash that we're seeing
uh that is kind of gaining momentum
because of how the way social media work
meaning that it works very much on like
Sensational content you would like push
Sensational content which sometimes we
struggle as Educators um as activist to
get our message across yes of course and
that's why like but we talked about it
previously the the need to also connect
uh different spheres and it's not just
about women's rights it's also about
like how do we manage the internet like
how what do we push forward like how do
we
education and um activism what sort of
Regulation what are the boundaries
around that on social media um content I
mean even with the wars we're seeing now
I mean there we are seeing ripe as a
weapon of War on our
doorstep so yeah how do we canot reg
this information well it's human rights
standards around the world and I mean
there is a push towards kind of
authoritarian regimes at present so you
know uh you've got to defend democracy
you know you've got to defend human
rights um the push towards more
authoritarian States it's it's very
disappointing I have to say for me to
see that but it's a reality that we need
to talk about we have to see how
precious our democracies are and value
them totally uh going back to the
directive and then I'll I'll leter um
are you happy with it how how do you
feel personally uh about the about it
well I'm concerned at the level of
resistance in relation to rape I'm very
pleased we have cyber violence well
covered in the directive that we have
female genital mutilation probably
sexual assault I I'm very pleased with
many of the aspects of you know
prevention more supports for women um
more protections and raising the
standards across Europe but I am
concerned at some of the resistances
particularly from the individual member
countries I I'm I'm delighted at the
standard we're setting from the
parliament's point of view the report
that's great very positive from the
commission but I'm obviously we've yet
to get into the detailed discussions on
rape so we have to see how that goes but
it's um a lot of uh legal concerns are
being stated by the member states so
we'll see how that develops okay well
good luck with that and I will let you I
will let you go now thank you very much
for answering my questions thank you not
at
all